[Music]
I'm Jeremiah Stambler the executive
director of the Chicago Health Research
Foundation an associate professor
Department of Medicine Northwestern
University Medical School I'm convinced
that a mass of evidence exists
demonstrating that diet is one of the
key factors responsible for the current
epidemic of severe mature severe
premature atherosclerosis in the United
States population and accounting for the
very high incidence of heart attacks in
the middle decades of life in our
country I'm dr. mark tiao Chuen Boston
Massachusetts I'm assistant professor of
medicine the Harvard Medical School
lecture and medicine at Yale University
and convinced that diet can now have a
primary role in the pathogenesis of
atherosclerosis
I'm dr. David Miller from the Atlanta
field investigations unit of the heart
disease and stroke control program the
US Public Health Service at the National
communicable disease Center in Atlanta
I'm here to serve as moderator for these
discussions of this critically important
subject
[Music]
welcome to the exploration of concepts
and controversies in modern medicine one
of a series of programs dedicated to
examining the uncertain candidly
recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon
opinion and that the opinions of eminent
physicians in a given field vary widely
the national medical audio-visual Center
believes that openly airing such
opposing views is a basic responsibility
of medical communications dr. david
miller national communicable disease
Center will act as moderator of this
presentation first dr. Jeremiah Stemler
will present some of the evidence from
his work and from that of others
suggesting strongly that diet and
atherosclerosis are causally related and
that appropriate changes in diet offer
the possibility of prevention of these
diseases dr. Stanley let me dr. Miller
first point out the scope of the problem
confronting us 600,000 coronary deaths a
year in the United States 165 thousand
of them in persons under 65 years of age
three men for every woman with about
twice as many non-fatal crippling events
this is one of the highest rates in the
world
not only compared to the less developed
countries of the world but also compared
to the developed countries of Europe the
British Commonwealth and so forth we
rank very near the top I think only the
Finns beat us out of this regard and I
guess we can say well I gave us we're
second but we're trying harder now study
after study of these international
differences both analyses of United
Nations data World Health Organization
data the very important international
autopsy study done by our colleagues at
the Louisiana State University Medical
School together with the very important
field studies of dr. Keyes and his group
in twelve different populations of
Europe plus the Japanese all show a very
close correlation
the pattern of the diet particularly the
saturated fat intake the dietary
cholesterol intake the serum lipids of
the populations under study and the
incidence and mortality rates as well as
the prevalence rates of coronary heart
disease that is a fatal and non-fatal
atherosclerosis of the major coronary
vessels now this is one of the most
important pieces of evidence I would
underline the fact that the distribution
of serum cholesterol in the population
the mean levels the rates of
hypercholesterolemia differ markedly
among these countries and along with
that the coronary rates differ and only
diet can explain these differences for
example countries like the Greek islands
of Corfu of Crete which have been
studied intensely southern Italy
Dalmatia Japan have much lower mean
serum cholesterol and triglyceride and
beta life of protein levels than we do
their coronary rates are much lower in
middle age this correlates directly with
their saturated fat and cholesterol
intakes it's importantly related also to
their intake of total calories but
there's a great deal of evidence to
implicate the fat component of the diet
as the most important one this is not to
say that this is the only dietary factor
nor is it to say that diet is the only
factor but it certainly is a key and
important one cigarette smoking also
enters into the picture and physical
inactivity as well as high blood
pressure and other risk factors may as
well I want to stress the diet is
involved in least in at least four ways
not just in relation to serum lipids
diet is of course related to overweight
diet and exercise or lack of exercise
are both related to overweight
overweight as well as high serum lipids
are connery risk factors in addition
diet is related through overweight to
risk of high blood pressure
fat people get more high blood pressure
than people who are lean throughout life
and diet is related to the risk of
diabetes again at least because fat
people
more diabetes than lean people and
hyperlipidemia overweight hypertension
and hyperglycemia or diabetes are all
major culinary risk factors I therefore
find it very difficult to believe that
diet is unrelated we also have the
massive evidence of experimental
atherosclerosis namely that the cynic
wha known for the reproduction of severe
atherosclerosis and our problem is not
just a thorough sclerosis in general all
of us have some of that none of us at
this moment are sick from it the thing
that makes for morbidity and mortality
is severe atherosclerosis and the only
way one can produce severe
atherosclerosis in species in the
laboratory
avian mammalian herbivores omnivorous
carnivorous including monkeys primates
is by feeding diets high in saturated
fats high in total fats high in
cholesterol and raising the blood lipid
levels particularly the blood
cholesterol levels and unless man is
radically different from all other
species and as a departure from the
basic laws of evolution I cannot but
regard this evidence is extremely
important finally we know from a vast
series of epidemiologic and clinical
investigative studies that by altering
the kinds of diets we're eating at the
present time we can shift the
distribution of serum lipids to the left
or in plain simpler English we can lower
the lipids not just of hyperlipidemia
people but of whole populations this was
shown in the National Diet Heart Study
in a double-blind controlled open
population study in an institution and
at the present time at least four major
long-term field trials in new york in
chicago in los angeles and helsinki
indicate that such nutritional changes
are associated with a decreased rate of
connery disease in middle-aged
individuals in brief summary then all of
these pieces of information strongly
indicate to me that diet is one of the
key factors
in the contemporary epidemic and that to
end this epidemic we must do something
about the diet as well as other major
risk factors such as cigarette smoking
and hypertension thank you doctor
stammer next dr. mark al shal will
present some of his views emphasizing
the inadequacies of the dietary data and
casting doubt upon the hypothesis that
diet is causally related to
atherosclerosis ease dr. al sure well
first let me say that there are certain
aspects of the dietary problem that we
all agree upon if a man's too fat we try
to reduce him if he has diabetes we
treat it with diet if he has
hypertension we may treat it with diet
but what I'd like to emphasize is that
these are only peripheral and in many
cases they're very subsidiaries factors
the main etiologic factors cannot be
diet and there's very little evidence to
support the view that there is any
connection for example the vast amounts
of animal work that has been done with
the feeling of cholesterol is imperfect
in several respects in order to get any
significant amount of atherosclerosis in
some of these animal species one left
elevate the blood cholesterol level to
about between 2000 and 4000 milligrams
now it's extremely rare for any man
sicker well to have a cholesterol level
over a thousand and most of us run
around 250 or 300 so that apply the data
obtained with levels of two three or
four thousand - what obtains in man with
a level where 300 is continue considered
high I don't think is very good logic
moreover there's some question about
whether the cholesterol that's
introduced into the diet of these
animals in order to produce
atherosclerosis it's quite the same as
the cholesterol we eat because it has to
be separated processed and purified and
there's one school of thought that
believes that certain impurities
developed in the handling of that
cholesterol it was in fact a toxic our
toxic products the damaged blood vessels
and
due to disease and it's not the
cholesterol per se but at any rate I
would say that the animal experiments
are most unconventional and particularly
with respect to where the fact that
certain species will have one strain in
which a very high cholesterol diet does
seem to produce after those groceries
but the same species with another strain
can take exactly the same diet they have
no at most ferocious of the law with
respect to the statistical studies the
epidemiologic studies in man they too of
course are imperfect the authors of the
report of the Helsinki study and of the
Los Angeles study in their own reports
said that their groups were not matched
the much los angeles in particular
referred to the fact that one of a group
fish smoked more than the other and they
hadn't taken that into account before
starving it they said they didn't think
it made any difference i don't know on
what basis these statistical studies
that would be required to establish in
man that the kind of diet to dr. stanley
refers to is the cause the primary cause
of atherosclerosis so huge that the
likelihood of their ever being carried
out his remotes have been papers on that
subject by epidemiologist and I won't go
into one of any detail because they've
already been covered the matter of
getting the blood cholesterol down is
interesting but I'm not sure how
important it is because we don't really
know where the cholesterol gold is after
it leaves the blood for example if you
just add a few parts per million of
cadmium to the drinking water of a rat
hero of the blood cholesterol by about
40 or 50 percent but the cholesterol
goes into the blood vessels and these
rats have much more at the most
corrosive and the rats without that
cadmium in drinking water so that's when
reports say that the cholesterol is
diminished by ten fifteen or twenty
percent unless such a report can say
where the cholesterol go
I don't think I'd be willing to accept
it as evidence for anything except an
interesting laboratory finding and
laboratory findings unless they're
directly related to clinical phenomena
can be extremely misleading as far as I
know there's only one phenomenon in
which a lowering of the blood
cholesterol has been related to an
increase in cholesterol breakdown and
that is good exercise if you give
radioactively tagged cholesterol to an
exercising animal or a man you can show
that carbon dioxide is coming off and
therefore what a cholesterol is being
broken down and other ways of lowering
or cholesterol levels in the blood don't
carry that implication really well I
think the emphasis should not
necessarily be in fact shouldn't it all
be on lowering a cholesterol the
emphasis should be on influencing the
cardiac status and when a patient is put
on a diet with a change in fat content
so on and if blood cholesterol goes down
15% but he loses 40 pounds in weight if
his cardiac science improves I'd be more
likely to related to more inclined to
related to the fact that he's lost some
weight
where have vent to the fact that his
blood level has changed and I believe
that levels of changes are 15 to 20
percent a level really amount to very
much
preface the blood cholesterol levels
very variable thing and if she would
take your blood for a patient who's not
likely to enjoy being stuck the blood
cholesterol will go up you get a fall
try reading the current practice of
advancing upon the patient with a large
syringe a large needle a toothy smile
and a comment this won't hurt a bit
is not likely to change the blood
cholesterol very much except in the
upward direction so I would say that
whatever other than chives red does not
support the view that diet is a primary
importance in the genesis of
atherosclerosis
thank you dr. Joshua you've raised some
important questions from animal
experimental work implying that much of
this work is
with overloaded animals from
epidemiologic work so just pointing out
the imperfections of some of it I shan't
summarise anymore but turned out a
doctor's family for his comment on some
of dr. L shows points well each of them
could be dealt with it's some length I'd
like for a moment for us to discuss the
experimental aspects I think that it is
true that many of the studies have dealt
with massive additions of cholesterol
and fat to the diet but this is not the
exclusive situation as a matter of fact
old and each Gogh himself the man who
began the experimental work was one of
the first to feed relatively small
quantities of cholesterol in natural
form let me add not as crystalline
chemical material but as eggs or milk or
animal tissue and he did so over long
periods of time with only modest
elevations dr. out Joule of blood
cholesterol into the two three and four
hundred range not into the couple
thousand range without the production of
massive organ cholesterol --ss but with
the production of significant
atherosclerosis dr. Katz dr. pic and I
did the same thing with chickens in the
laboratory at Michael Reese what we did
was to give less of the cholesterol and
fat in the diet over a longer period of
time thereby mimicking in the
composition of the diet very closely the
kind of diet that's being eaten at the
present time in the United States dr.
Bruce Taylor has done the same thing
with monkeys and I guess one of the
neatest experiments in this regard is by
dr. Robert Whistler at the University of
Chicago who's fed two different diets
the primates first the usual American
diet no synthetic cholesterol added the
child a grub such as weed at every day
day in and day out most of us in the
United States today versus the so-called
prudent diet of the New York anti
Connery Club the kind of diet that we've
been recommending through the Heart
Association through our
very prevention program in those
primates only a moderate elevation of
cholesterol ensued in the first group
eating the usual American diet again no
organ cholesterol psious but again
definite atherosclerosis developed so I
think there's no doubt from primate
studies from rabbit studies from chicken
studies that you can reproduce the
lesions
of human atherosclerosis in a variety of
species by dietary means of a longer
duration but sort of corresponding what
goes to what goes on over our lifespan
because it does take three four five
decades from the time we begin eating
the American diet so that our blood
cholesterol rises from the cord blood
level of 80 up to about a hundred and
eighty or 190 by age 20 and up to about
two thirty by age 30 this is the
American pattern we used to say that
this was physiological this was the
normal human response until we began to
go out and look at other populations in
the Japanese it goes from cord blood 80
to 140 or 150 by middle-aged in southern
Italy to 160 or 170 where the total life
expectancy is better than ours the total
death rate in middle-aged is much less
than ours the coronary death rate much
much less than ours so I think this
argument about cholesterol psious and
massive feeding is only part of the
truth on this question
I agree also with dr. Sandler about the
invalidity of the studies in which such
high amounts of cholesterol were given
that cholesterol was deposited in the
blood vessels and a state of cholesterol
cyst development what I was referring to
rather was the fact that cholesterol
even in smaller amounts produces anemia
in experimental animals and if you were
the fact that a considerable amount of
evidence has been accumulated that shows
that the endothelium of the arteries is
a barrier to cholesterol infiltration
until damaged and the fact that hypoxia
is one factor that will damage the
lining
I think cholesterol
maybe toxic without producing massive
deposits that we both deplore in these
experiments and I might add that the
hypoxic factor of damage to the
endothelium probably explains the
propensity of heavy smokers to develop
atherosclerosis because they carry about
a 10 percent saturation of carbon
monoxide in their blood all the time
which is enough to damage the vessels
I'd like to pick up one other statement
- dr. Stanley made he said that the
experimental animal developed a kind of
atherosclerosis that was much like the
human however and the conference held in
New York about a year ago the New York
Academy of Sciences one of the
experimenters with primates made a
specific statement that animal
Exceptionalist grossest had never
reproduced what we saw in man that to be
taken both ways it might be species
different or differences or it might be
a truly significant difference between
the experimental and the natural I'd
like to enlarge a bit on the matter of
the endothelium as a barrier the
hypothesis was developed chiefly in
Scandinavia but has appeared in the
American literature and paper vais
silversmiths in human and I think the
point is well made that a host of
factors may damage endothelium and allow
cholesterol which would come through and
very small amount to accumulate and that
the cholesterol is not the cause of the
Essos grossest is this lesion of the
endothelium itself in that along those
lines we have the experiments by tatak
on the production of material lesions by
a humeral fact you're not involving
cholesterol at all and of course when it
comes to a consideration of what's the
possible primary factor after a genesis
is I think we can have recourse only to
the work of Texan which studied the
hemodynamic factors and draws out the
importance of them I should like also to
point out that although cholesterol
levels may be predictive in Framingham
mass and not at all predictive in Hawaii
and so when we come to factors that are
predictive in one place and not in
another I think we have to look behind
them for their true significance I
wonder if we might at this point agree
perhaps to disagree on some of the
animal experimental and pathologic work
and get into the epidemiologic work and
especially the subject of what might be
or what might not be recommended to
patients or to the American public in
the way of dietary change in the hope
that it might forestall some of this
morbidity and mortality well I agree dr.
Stanley would you but I'd like to start
in that discussion with a set of facts
we have just looked at both our own
study in the people's gas company and in
the pooled data of six studies
Framingham Albany Los Angeles civil
servants the Minneapolis businessman the
Western Electric study in Chicago and
our gas company study and we're
impressed by the fact that there are
unfortunately a minority of Americans
with serum cholesterol levels under 250
the average for this cut being about 210
with normal blood pressure and without
cigarette smoking and these people fare
remarkably differently from the great
mass of Americans with high lipid levels
with or without one another of these
factors in fact if one does five seven
and ten-year life tables on these people
the coronary death rate the sudden death
rate is about one-sixth that of the
population that has the traits I've
mentioned and total mortality is about a
half now I think we can make one simple
recommendation and as a matter of fact I
find this to be a universally supported
and I hope dr. al Chill supports it and
that is certainly we should go after
those high risk people who are extremely
coronary prone in our population
and aside from controlling their
hypertension and their overweight in
their hyperglycemia
and their cigarette smoking do something
also to ship their lipids over to the
low risk group so that we can buy them
some protection against the very high
risk they have at the present time from
all our experience a reduction in
saturated fat intake and cholesterol
intake if you will the Mediterranean I'm
stumbling over that hard word of the
American diet which incidentally permits
a very pleasant eating and which can
lower the cholesterol fifteen or twenty
percent very easily for high lipid
people this kind of approach should
certainly be fruitful for high-risk
people hey may I stop now and ask doctor
I'll show his reaction to that what in
view of the imperfections of the data
thus far what do you think should be
recommended for now in the future well I
think that people should not be pigs and
they should eat reasonably and if a
man's fatty should be thinned down but
beyond that I don't see that there's any
need to limit the kind or specific kind
of food we all know that there are large
variations even within families of the
selection of food and yet the whole
family may have coronary disease in fact
they may all die of it before they're
very old
we were matter of an excess of
unsaturated fat bothers me a little
because it can become toxic and whether
or not unsaturated fat can give rise to
intima lesions is still a matter of
discussion but doing large amounts of
clay definitely is toxic and animals
another thing that I think is somewhat
important is the fact that eating is has
more than caloric significance it has a
social and an emotional significance and
I have dined with some friends of mine
or on this low cholesterol high
unsaturated fatty acid cake and I must
say I'll never go back to dinner at
those homes again let me attempt to
summarize first by emphasizing some of
the points on which we agreed that
morbidity and mortality from
atherosclerosis
presents a tremendous health problem in
this country and in other industrialized
countries that central to the core of
understanding these diseases and of
their cause lies disturbed lipid
metabolism and that there are multiple
other causes which are complex ly
interrelated and very difficult to
separate and enumerate anyone we have
not agreed as to the role played by diet
I think dr. Stemler believes that it is
a primary importance and I believe you
ibly believe that it is of secondary
importance we have agreed I believe that
something needs to be done more
effectively than we now are doing about
these diseases and I hope that at future
time at some future time we may be able
to come to this sort of agreement we
thank dr. Jeremiah stammer dr. mark al
Jewell and dr. David Miller for their
interesting analysis of a critical
problem in patient care in subsequent
programs we shall continue to record
equally significant concepts and
controversies in modern medicine the
opinions expressed on this program do
not necessarily constitute endorsement
by the Department of Health Education
and Welfare the Public Health Service or
its constituent
[Music]